hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar
advanced optical hematology technology for better analytical performance i
am cristian leiva from abbott
hematology and you will be your moderator for
today's event today's educational webinar
is presented by the wdcs
and brought to you  by abbott
diagnostics for more information you
can visit www laboratory
point abbott slash point hematology
so let's get
started before we start i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
to  Simply write your
query in the ask box and
click submit We will answer as many
questions as time allows at the
end of the presentation
If you have trouble viewing or
listening to the presentation Click the
Support tab at the
top  right of the display window
report your problem by clicking
on the access ask a question
located on the far left of the
screen
this presentation is educational and
therefore offers
continuing education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tabs
located on the top  right of
the submission window and follow the
process to get your credits
now submit this now from schedule
doctor 6 you will like
that abbott
hematology doctor time was not working as
global manager of medical and scientific affairs
for office-based theology  de abbott from 15 in germany
is a medical doctor majoring at the
university of bristol uk- in
hematology blood transfusion and
transplantation medicine
for a full bio
on our work nothing visit the
bio tab at the
top of the screen
it matters  mention that this
webinar is a repetition
translated into Spanish  English of the
additional version transmitted by this same
medium a few months ago
we started the presentation
and thanks for the presentation I
welcome you to today's webinar series
on advanced optical technology that
allows better analytical performance
this conference oil program is
sponsored by and  on behalf of abbott
laboratories and the content of this
presentation is consistent with
all applicable fed requirements
getting into the topic hematology analyzers
are available from various
manufacturers and employ different
detection methods today i will discuss the
general principles of optical technology
and how to improve cell analysis
and overcome the limitations
commonly seen with impedance
then I will continue with the presentation of
align and ex iris and explain
advanced mapping technology by describing the
analytical approach to
white blood cells platelets red blood cells and
reticulocytes with case demonstrations related to
evantes
the line the eight services system
integrates the hematology workflow
from high performance complete blood count analysis
to full automation of blood
smear smearing and staining
is currently available
as a stand-alone analyzer and also
as an integrated system with the
smear extender and staining module
the system offers a solution to many
of the limitations of the laboratory to
focus on the reliability of a
system that provides high performance
reporting 119 programs per hour for
each analyzer system at the inadi age
club you
process 197 more demogrã per
square meter  achieving one of the highest
performances on the market integrates
analyzer module and extender module and
smear staining to reduce manual intervention
requires only three reagents
simplifying reagent management
reporting full
six part differential and reticulocyte counting
allows for continuous loading of d  e the reagents
that come in small
volume containers for uninterrupted operation
and together with the robust
mirol web solution
to harmonize
laboratory operations providing greater
productivity now let's take a look at
the technology aline
and it services technology uses flow cytometry
which is based on a
light scattering or
optical + fluorescence analysis system using an
alignment-free optical bench to
report a 6-part differential
the use of nuclear fluorescent staining
allows recognition of
nucleated red blood cells and resistant red blood cells
allowing  include
analysis of nucleated red blood cells
in each blood count
by incorporating the principle
of light scattering based on me theory and
using transformation algorithms
red blood cells are identified in
terms of cell-to-cell volume
removing the
matching constraints of the
impedance analyzers  and volume measurements
also provides
cell-to-cell hemoglobin concentration
algorithms and
reticulocyte stain used at allied
irish allow analysis of
reticulated platelets to be included with every
reticulocyte analysis
as we know electrical impedance was
the first automated technology to
count cells and also to measure the
size of white blood
cells red blood cells and platelets
impedance is based on the measurement of
changes in electrical current that
are produced by particles
suspended in a conductive liquid
as they pass through an opening to
As the particle passes through the
opening, the change in
resistance between the electrodes is reduced, which
is measured to determine the number of
particles and their associated volume. One of
the difficulties associated with
impedance-based measurement is in
controlling irregular recirculation of
white blood cells and  As other cells
around the aperture detection zone
that
signal duplication interference by the same
cells requires correction for
impedance this could be the result
of a correction formula however
there was no way to correct
the volume measurement simply by applying  the
point of correction of two cells
passing through the detection zone near
the wall of the aperture where there is
high density electric current with
the introduction of
hydrodynamic approach the orderly passage
of cells through a
detection zone and the technologies
Automated hematology clinics were able to
move towards
optical-based methods for cell categorization and
counting. These aligned cells
were then passed through an
optical interrogation point where
light signals at different angles are generated from
each passing cell giving information
about the size of the cell.  cell the
internal structure its granularity
like surface morphology,
applications such as
cytochemical staining or fluorescence can also
be combined with optical methodology
to provide more information
about the cell population
let's move on to maps technology
maps means separation of multiple
polarized light scattering
angles a technology
patented by aline bots and the age you
uses an advanced version of
maps technology with three
additional light scattering detectors as can
be seen in this figure a
focused laser beam is scattered by
cells moving through a
flow cell the detectors at the emirates that
measure the scattering of laser light in
different directions and use it to
identify cells
this works in conjunction with the
fluorescence detector to
provide a complete
blood cell count or complete blood cell count
the first angle at which  I want to
refer to it, it is used to
det  erminate the size of the cell the
second angle is 90 degrees for the
light scattering that is detected by
the polarized light detector or pss this
provides information on
nuclear segmentation the third angle is
the set of detectors that make up
the scattering of the cell  medium light and at
that the allied irish has four
detectors set between 2.5 and 7.5
degrees
these angles measure the
internal complexity of the cell giving an idea
about the volume of
hemoglobin content and cell granulation
these angles also help to
differentiate large platelets from small
small or fragmented red blood cells
last angle is for depolarized
light scattering at 90 degrees or ss
to detect depolarized light scattering
just like polarized light scattering
is set to 90 degrees but
instead of polarized light look for light  is
polarized and this is important in
identifying the presence of granules such
as those found in
eosinophils the eight signals obtained
by using maps has advanced generated
by a cell scattering light and
emitting fluorescence are represented on
this slide
as you can see the table
lists the various
scattering angles and fluorescence detection
what each measures  one of
them and the application in which
the axial light loss detector is used
is measured for cell size by
the new matrix that detects
intermediate angle scattering and is measured and
provides information on the
cellular complexity of red blood cells
platelets hemoglobin and
reticulocytes supplemented by
size information
pss polarized scattering separation
detector assesses nuclear segmentation ss
depolarized scattering separation detector
provides specific information
on them and not phyla and fl 1 detector
measures fluorescence at 530 nanometers
which to quantify the intensity
of acid fluorescence  The nucleics that
characterize a positive coloration in
the analyzed cell
the Alinghi age reported 29 parameters
that are mentioned in this screen when you
are processing in the CBC mode plus
differential plus reticulocytes the
tic mode parameters are the
fraction of immature reticulocytes the
mean corpuscular hemoglobin  of the
reticulum cited concentration and
percentage of reticulocytes along with
this nucleated red blood cells and
reticulated platelets are also
available with each complete
blood count result plus
differential reticulocyte mean corpuscular hemoglobin parameter
is also
reported which has proven to be a
good predictor  in iron deficiency anemia
according to several studies as it is known
compared to erythrocytes the
shorter lifespan of reticulocytes makes
this parameter a better biomarker
reflecting short-term iron status
and also gives a
snapshot of iron availability
p  For erythropoiesis
this table shows morphology alerts
on albir and youtube
in the presence of aggregated platelets
variant lymphocytes and blasts
most labs will perform a
smear review
no further action is needed in the
case left shift
however each lab  make the
decision according to their
internal procedures note that
aggregated platelet alerts can also
indicate the presence of large platelets
in the presence of
red blood cell fragments alert
most laboratories will do a
smear and review
it however not  additional actions are necessary such
as correcting the
white blood cell count in the case
of unlisted red blood cells as
these cells do not interfere with the
white blood cell count
in the case of hemoglobin interference alert it
is recommended to
visually inspect the sample
as the  alert can be triggered by
l  line or hemolysis and can also be
caused by insufficient samples or in the
presence of clots
now I will refer to the analytical approach
of alimer and ex iris for white blood
cells and I will show some cases
we know that there are several approaches that have
been adopted by hematology analyzers
that  use laser optics
and fluorescence technology whether
multiple channels are used for
WBC analysis with multiple
reagents of different
issys intensities modular approaches to choose
sequential analysis modes adoption
of different techniques to reduce
interference primarily from
red blood cells  resistant and
giant platelets may cause
falsely low or high counts
quality and age design is unique in that it
uses a single and simpler channel
allowing counting of
nucleated red blood cells with each
blood count result white blood cell reagent
contains a dye  cat  ionic
fluorescent selective for nucleic
acids which takes the nucleus of
cells and makes it fluorescent the
reagent removes the
cytoplasmic membrane of the red blood cell
so that
in the nucleated red blood cells
present the entire nuclei stain and
flourish the membranes of the
white blood cells are maintained  intact but are
permeable to dye therefore
also flourish therefore
white blood cell reagent allows to
differentiate white blood
cells from red blood cells resistant to analysis
thus align and age towards the count of
nucleated red blood cells with each
complete demogram generating results
Furthermore, the inclusion of
additional light scattering angles
that we discussed above and
additional algorithms allow the
reporting of immature granulocytes both
the absolute number and a percentage
to the ibi the edge that reports the
WBC differential in six
parts with data from count and
percentage  aje of immature granulocytes and
along with it also reports
nucleated red blood cells as count and
concentration per 100
white blood cells without interfering with
white blood cell count
no correction in
white blood cell count is required even in the
presence of red blood cells  nucleated
this slide shows the scattered
grams essential for analyzing
white blood cells as seen on the
left the first graph corresponds
to size see your a polarized scattering separation
l l versus pss shows the
difference between segmented
and non-segmented cells which are
nuclear polymorph cells  and mononuclear
respectively the second one below is the
scattergram of internal complexity
versus the size y a that versus the l y
is the main graph to analyze the
leukocyte differential as can
be seen here
the third scattergram is the
separation of polarized scattering
versus separation of dispersion
pss versus dss depolarized
scattering this scattering is very useful to see
eosinophils shown in green
differ from neutrophils by their
unique ability to depolarize
light 90 degrees due to the granules
within said cell the latter
bottom right  is the fluorescence versus
size
eph l 1 versus the one showing
nucleated red blood cells when
present are red in the
lower right area and characterized
by their small size and highly fluorescent intensity we will
discuss something
about resistant red blood cells
analysis as  It is known that the increased
resistance of red blood cells
analysis occurs in certain
conditions and sometimes also
physiologically in the newborn, the
premature baby and in certain hemoglobinopathies
, however this interference in the
inadi age you does not in fact affect the
cell count as described.  you can see in
the scatter plots they are also
clearly identified  and show
valid results from the first
analysis it has a higher efficiency at the
first step and this identification of
resistant red blood cells by
hematology analyzers has
shown to be diagnostic in many
studies we continue talking about
nucleated red blood cells in this case
we will focus on the analysis of
white blood cells so this patient
presents a complex case with
leukocytosis with absolute
neutrophilia and high neutrophil count 86%
in differential there is a
left shift alert and indicates
high number of banded
neutrophils immature granulocytes and granulocytes
nucleated red blood cells are also
present and were counted separately
manual differential found a high
percentage of banded neutrophils
consistent with the left shift alert
the number of
immature granulocytes that are meta honey bears honey
bears and prize cited it are observed
in the smear and is consistent  with
aline skiff counting
manual and automated red blood cell counting
also agrees importantly
by inhibiting and age you can differentiate
nucleated red blood cells from
white blood cells and count them
separately
so there is no need to correct the
blood cell count  white by the
presence of nucleated red blood cells
these do not interfere with the analysis of
white blood cells this class of
alteration can have various etiologies
for example hemolysis hemoglobinopathies
trauma acute bleeding myelodysplasia or
leukemia looking at these scattered dramas it is
interesting to see the graph of the
scatter of the  differential the plot of
size versus intermediate angle dispersion
shows nucleated red blood cells
in red at the
bottom left of the graph and are
separated from all other
non-white blood cell events that you can
see in gray and do not interfere with the
differential analysis  of white blood cells
so no correction is required
in the white blood cell
count the same way on this
slide when comparing the case of
nucleated red blood cells to a normal sample we
will look at fluorescence
versus size the population of
red nucleated red blood
cells is in the  bottom
right of graph due to its small
size and high
fluorescence intensity this population
is not normally present in samples with the
exception of especially
premature neonates in whom nucleated red blood cells
may be physiologically present
in conclusion when using at inadi age
the  nucleated red blood cells result
does not interfere
with white blood cell counts this is an
interesting case in which the
blood count result shows leukocytosis with
neutral philia absolute
immature granulocytes and a
left shift alert with high
immature granulocyte count the alert
deviate  The deviation to the left indicates the
presence of banded neutrophils and it is
important to emphasize that it does not invalidate the
result.
The manual differential found a high
percentage of banded neutrophils
consistent with the alert deviation
to the left and the number of
immature granulocytes that are meta honey.
honey bears honey bears and prom and the sites
observed in the smears is consistent with
the immature granulocyte count
reported by aline de age this
alert situation
left deviation of neutrophils with the presence
of immature granulocytes is a
relatively common finding often
associated with
inflammation  and neoplasm particularly
myeloproliferative neoplasms such as
chronic myeloid leukemia so now
we will move on to look
at aline and age's analytical approach
to analysis of red blood cells and
platelets with discussion of some cases
prior to analysis red blood cells
are expressed for  remove the effect
of origin  entation of the red blood cell
when analyzed in an optical detection system
as can be seen in the figure
normally the red blood cells are
deformable bi-concave discs as they are
be concave if the superficial attention changes
the red blood cells can
change their shape to spheres of
unaltered volume  and detectable then the
measurement signal produced in the
flow cell is not affected by
cell orientation red blood
cell platelets and associated measurements
are processed from
optical light scattering information
using various measurement signals.  scattering
the application of the spherical effect
multiple angles
of light scattering allow for better separation of
red blood cells from platelets in
addition to the inadi age it also measures
red blood cell volume cell by
cell based on the me theory of
scattering of the  light, as can be seen
in the figure, the measurement of the
intermediate scattering angle also  It does
provide the
hemoglobin concentration cell by cell it is
interesting that the
mean corpuscular hemoglobin in
reticulocytes is also reported when doing
reticulocyte analysis
so what are the benefits of
this multidimensional analysis let's take
a look at the slide the
benefits of multidimensional analysis
are  they are best seen when platelets and
red blood cells are similar in size
and such situations occur when
there are microcytic red blood
cells segmented red blood cells large or
giant platelets in these cases impedance or
light scattering technology at
two angles may show overlap
of  the signal using
multidimensional analysis different
measurement angles of light scattering
produce unique signal patterns
even when platelets and
red blood cells are the same size so
we now know that
accurate platelet counting is possible
ba  xed the optical method with this
methodology however in some
analyzers
additional channels and reagents are still needed which not
only affect the reporting time
but also increase the cost of the complete
blood count
and here we are going to discuss something related
to fragmented red blood cells
a significant finding  Regarding the
red blood cell and the planetary parameter, it
is the fragmented red blood cell alert
whose presence impacts the
red blood cell count and platelets as well as their
associated parameters, as can be seen
in this case for the data highlighted
in red, this patient presented
with anemia along with  a low hemoglobin
low hematocrit low
red blood cell count and high psm as can be
seen we also see rings and ptosis with a
high erythrocyte distribution width
and high concentration of
reticulocytes with a percentage of 4.8
percent the smear review
also found a slight  increased
polychrome ya janis o quoted sis
consistent with elevated reticulocyte count
and an
increase in
red cell distribution width is quite evident smear also
reveals morbid number of schists and
edging cough and cough and equine and
cough smear also confirms
elevated bsm and low count  of platelets
now when looking at the
scatter plot of this case and comparing it to
a normal sample you can see the
presence of
red blood cell fragments in the plot of size l l versus
y a s 3 and in the plot of iu
s 2 versus y a s 3 which show
clearly overlap along
the x-axis between the
red blood cell pool and platelets suggesting the
presence of
red blood cell fragments of similar size to platelets
however the
red blood cell and platelet populations are clearly
separated along the y-axis  this is
due to the result of differences
in their internal complexity and
light scattering characteristics
so that  It is important to note that
the multidimensional analysis of
platelets that we discussed earlier allows for
this separation in most
circumstances
avoiding the problems found
in impedance-based hematology analyzers where
falsely high platelet counts can be seen in such
situations. This is a case in point.  very
interesting platelet clumping
in this case we will focus on the
aggregated platelet alert as you can
see the alert is present which
generates an invalid platelet count
as well as associated
parameters shown in red
smear review confirms the presence  of
moderate amounts of platelets
aggregated in variable sizes in this
case the platelet count is normal
but unreportable because it does not
include platelets that are clumped the
patient also has
normal chronic normoanemia and atica the
scatterplot shows gray events
that represent the  s platelets aggregated
and clearly differentiated from
white blood cells but do not interfere
with WBC analysis
some hematology analyzers still
cannot detect this and show
false white blood cells and because
platelet clumps are
large enough and similar in
size  of white blood cells
counting them as such looking at the
scatter plot in this particular case and
compared to a normal one shows a
characteristic pattern that is specific
to platelet clumping, the
positioning of aggregated platelets
and the lymphocyte population
along  from a l l on the x-axis suggests
that their size is similar however
using
y-axis polarized side scatter the two populations are
separate and have no
interference with the
leukocyte count or
differential result similarly if we look at
below the two scattered gr plus the
fluorescence versus t  rigging you can see
that they are clearly separated where the
aggregated platelets are
clearly separated from the white blood cells and
thus do not interfere with the analysis
of white blood cells
and the differential I will
now proceed to explain the
analytical approach for reticulocytes in the
albeniz of Asterix and discuss  A case
in point
this figure as you can see on the
slide is an interesting
scatterplot that represents the measurement of
reticulocytes the x axis is the
relative size based on the measurement and the l and
the y axis is the green fluorescence
which is positive in  presence of
nucleic acid the reticulocyte reagent
uses a fluorescence stain
that binds to air in found in
reticulocytes
whenever we call the retics mode
on the instrument an aliquot is taken
from the dilution of red blood cells
platelets the algorithm separates
red blood cells from  white blood cells
and platelets depending on the size and
intensity of the  fluorescence then
differentiates mature red blood cells
from reticulocytes by their high
fluorescence using a dynamic threshold
plus a second dynamic threshold separates
the
highest fluorescent intensity immature
reticulocyte fraction from mature reticulocytes as you can see
here the mature platelets in yellow
are also separated  of the
reticulated and mature platelets shown in
blue
and this particular reticulocyte method
also allows you to align and
display the mean corpuscular hemoglobin
of the reticulocyte
which is also a very important parameter
now looking at this case with
increased reticulocyte concentration
As the report shows, this patient
has normal-cytic to chronic-normal anemia
with low red blood cell counts,
hemoglobin and hematocrit, there is also the
presence of nucleated red blood cells,
the white blood cell count is high,
and there are low platelets with an increase
in the number of  reticulated platelets the
graph shows that the concentration of
reticulated platelets is high which
shows that the bone marrow is very
active in an attempt to replace the
missing red blood cells
the reticulocyte count reflects the
erythropoietic activity of the bone
marrow therefore it is very useful  both in
the diagnosis of anemia and in the
monitoring of the bone
marrow response to therapy
as you can see in the
cross-linked platelet analysis does not require any
change in mode does not require any
type of additional reagent does not require
any other application the
Articulated platelets are also an
integral part of the analysis of
milestone articles in the inadi age, as we know they
have a very short life in the
peripheral circulation, for this reason they act
as a marker of mega-
carousal activity in the bone marrow, which
gives them clinical utility.  and diagnosis
in this particular case there is the
possibility of various etiologies such as
thrombotic thrombocytopenic purpura hemolysis microangiopathic hemolytic
anemia or bone marrow
recovering after
chemotherapy however when comparing this case with a
normal sample we can clearly see
that the reticulocyte population is more
prominent compared to an
anthologically normal sample which
is consistent with a  higher value in the
percentage of reticulocytes detected
by aline and in fact compared to
a normal graph the population of
platelets also extends
along both axes we evidence the presence
of large platelets and a greater number
of reticulated platelets showing
fluorescence intensity
relatively higher in this case the
increase in both size and
rn content implies an increase in the
population of very immature platelets in
this case we see the same
scatterplot but the scatterplot
is revealing the comparison measured
size reticulated platelets  HE  Well,
using the same reagent that is
used for the
reticulocyte count and they are detected in
the reticulocyte channel
in the inadi, it is possible to have this
parameter without any additional application of
additional reagent and without
impacting the reporting time as it
happens in many other systems.
Measurement of immature reticulate platelets
has proven clinical utility
in many patients
etiology of
thrombocytopenia is unknown Reticular platelet is
used for monitoring
bone marrow recovery after
chemotherapy and for monitoring
stem cell transplantation Studies
also show that  has a role in
the etiology of coronary heart disease
now i will summarize the presentation and
try to give a
conceptual overview of alinghi age state of the art technology
additionally we discuss in detail
various analytical principles on the
analysis of red blood cells
white blood cells platelets and reticulocyte  s and
finally we discuss six
specific cases to demonstrate the
improvement in the accuracy of the
cellular analysis of this technology that
offers greater efficiency and confidence in
the results we
appreciate the presentation of elector
otay nada now we will start the round of
questions and live parties
about this terminal  virtual
to answer your questions we are
joined by will jimenez who is a
water support specialist we have
tics and will be able to answer in spanish
if you have any questions you would like to
bring please and now just
click on the ask a question link
located on the far left of  the
screen we will answer as many
questions as the remaining time allows
let's start our first question
stop one is
what are the clinical and
operational benefits of having a system that is
all optical
thanks christina
the direct benefit is less
manual intervention as well as
iterations and corrections  d  e count
required to perform cases that for a
long time have been a challenge for
hematology analyzers
almost as in trends in counts
due to these nucleated landmarks
platelet aggregates giant packages or these
micro and ticos among many others
also alarms in abnormal populations
deposits
and good  the advantage of having a
reliable result the first time without the need for
special reactive modes
raw textures for
berta and colon samples
the next question we have he
mentioned that I do has an
advanced methodology how to improve this
the low definition of platelets when
there are micro milestones or  debris in the eye
with sea optics technology
edith platelets micro physical bears and
cellular debris have a different pattern
of light scattering
this is what is used
to differentiate their features
regardless of whether they are the
same size they can in some  cases
have the same size pe  ro with the
sensors that have high
light scattering sensitivity as
seen in the presentation at different
angles such
as days 1 and 2 days 3 as
the presentation will show then with these
light scattering characteristics the
analyzer is
to distinguish independently  only
the size between,
as I mentioned, micro eyes,
cellular remains, the giant ones,
or other signs that can cause
noise,
the pectoral, we have here for learning purposes,
the minister will deviate from the presentation
if this presentation will be available
after speaking
when we are only going to respond shortly
about the  friends milestones where
we observed them
yes cristian as I commented in the
presentation it was shown that the line h
is capable of reporting ripe grains the
parameter y g
which is made up of the milestones but
less milestones and me also the sites those
three will be part of the count of  great
immature sites
who will ask you a
particular el bolillo the medi  Or is it a
critical parameter in the laboratory, how does this new
technology obtain said parameter
and well, in this case, my
theorem is the theorem in providing the
mathematical elements to determine the volume
of an experimental element based on
light scattering patterns,
then more  advanced uses this
theorem that measures the dispersion of light of
each district expressed without the need for
corrections using this principle
then based on the angles of
dispersion of light is the steel is
able to know the volume of each
cited right this technology is very
sensitive  It is even capable of detecting
changes in cell volume due to
oxygenation of the hemoglobin
within the electrolyte. He quoted, for example, it is
still perfect because we have
produced one last question
because it is in the cases
of high percentage nucleated red blood cells. It is
possible that there is an error in  the
measurement or here could be due
well let's remember that all the
distinction of population  lations,
the analyzer will use the
measurement elements, such as
light scattering and fluorescence in this case,
then the clear algorithm will try
to distinguish the milestones
created based on their size and the fluorescence
they emit. It
is possible, of course, that in some  cases
any
cell population that
is in the same range of size and your
essence of the facts milestones can be
counted as deposits however
well we do our best because the
algorithms try to avoid this on the
side but like all algorithms it is
based on these measurements and if  There is
some noise or signal that complies with that
measurement with these characteristics, it
can be counted as such,
but here we have this interesting question in full,
how many reagents does the
h system use to work
because at the h limit,
well, an interesting characteristic of
the h limit,
speaking of reagents, is that  reagents can be
changed when the
instrument you are working on has a
system  ema duplicate reagents so
even if it is processing there is no
need to pause
or stop the analyzer to
replace or additional assets
then
and diluents are going to be used
people read tico for w about these are
the reagents for molina 3
and good articles on  file for the
title there are four reagents that you
use and you will also
have people for cleaning
so counting in the people of
intimate cleanings there
are actually 4 reagents
the question is known about the
detection limit and linearity for the
red blood cell count  nucleated or
reticulocytes
and we have the specifications in the
sense of linearity
for these parameters are in
the analyzer operations manual
not only for the parameters but for
others
for more details regarding this
information please contact your
local representative
and with  pleasure we will test these
specifications directly
the talk presents very interesting the
The team presents as part of its work
some cleaning after reading
each sample, how we make sure to
avoid carryover between our sample
and well, the analyzer has a
rinsing process for the
aspiration probe and all the
elements that are obviously in
contact with the sample.  dilution of the sample
then after before and after each
process it will perform a cleaning
now as part of the variation of the
instruments always good because we are doing
a cardio carry test to see to
make sure
that everything is within specifications
but good responding  to the question is
if we have a cleaning system between
each aspiration before and after
we will deal with here a very interesting question
in the lyric h can we pass
blood samples yes treated to
correct adding the effect of planetary aggregates
well we do not have a specification in
the  operations manual
any kind of d
[Music]
is like this is any t  Types of
processes such as these can be validated
internally or within the laboratory
based
on procedures that already exist to carry out
this type of evaluation specifically
with citrate tubes, so
we do not have formal validation in the
operations manual, but if the
laboratory wishes, it can proceed to
do your own validation for this
type of tubes
perfect i think we have time for
one more question
what are the key features of
a limit that customers can now
use to make their daily lives easier
if in addition to the technology part
already discussed  It was also presented, there are also
useful operational advantages in the
daily routine, as I had mentioned,
for example, the ability to change
assets without stopping the analyzer,
the characteristic that user
maintenance can be scheduled,
both daily and weekly,
both daily and weekly can help you
schedule at any time without
user intervention
The analyzer will also perform it automatically.
Another element is that it shares
design elements in terms of software
and use with other water analyzers at the
limit for chemistry, entity for
immunology, city s, for blood banks,
so we have common software,
common characteristics,
connection and monitoring.  remote from abbott
link for everyone, so this means that
in laboratories that have personnel who
process the different areas
and can touch a team the
chemistry index at 30 h of hepatology because it
is practically the same operating system
these are some of the
examples that  it has issued in fact
to make the daily routine a little
easier for everyone
excellent lithium thanks for defending
the queries I don't know if you have any
final comments for our audience
and thanks cristian well actually
thanks for your participation and well if there are
others we know that  if you have any other
questions let us know via email and
we will try  to answer your questions
either through the mail or directly
by one of your local representatives
in the country with this stand
and well thank you very much for your attention and
you know that we are here for any
questions or comments thank
you once again to raúl jiménez for
being  with us and also doctors
there is nothing in your pre-presentation
you would also like to thank bar
woods and our sponsor
aouate diagnosticians for writing
today's virtual education webinar
before we go i would like to
thank all the audience for
joining us poetically  your interesting
questions the questions that we do not have
time to see now and those that will be
sent by you in the
seminar period will be adopted by the
presenter through the
contact information that you provided us
at the time of registration the webcam will be
able to see  on demand for the
next six months
and discourage your email  nico
when it is available for
return
we encourage you to share this message
with your colleagues who may have
missed the event today until
a next time
goodbye right